is the microphone on I believe it is now
is that yes perfect thank you again mr.
chairman mr. chairman ranking member
newness and members of the committee
thank you for inviting me to testify
before you today I have a short opening
statement
I appreciate the importance of
congresses impeachment inquiry and I'm
appearing today as a fact witness as I
did during my deposition on October 14th
in order to answer your questions about
what I saw what I did what I knew and
what I know with regard to the subjects
of your inquiry I believe that those who
have information that the Congress deems
relevant have a legal and a moral
obligation to provide it I take great
pride in the fact that I'm a non
partisan foreign policy expert who was
served under three Republican and
Democratic presidents I have no interest
in advancing outcome of your inquiry in
any particular direction except toward
the truth I will not provide a long
narrative statement because I believe
that the interest of Congress and the
American people is best served by a but
allowing you to ask me your questions
and I'm happy to expand upon my October
14th deposition testimony and respond to
your questions today
but before I do so I'd like to
communicate two things first I'd like to
show a little bit about Who I am I'm an
American by choice having become a
citizen in 2002 I was born in northeast
of England in the same region that
George Washington's ancestors came from
both my region and my family have deep
ties to the United States my paternal
grandfather fought through World War one
in the Royal Field Artillery surviving
being shot shelled and gassed before
American troops intervened to end the
war in 1918 during the Second World War
other members of my family fought to
defend the free world from fascism
alongside American soldiers sailors and
airmen the men in my father's family
were coal miners his family was always
struggled with poverty
well my father Alfred was 14
joined his father brothers brother
uncles and cousins in the coal mines
help put food on the table when the last
of the local mines closed in the 1960s
my father wanted to emigrate to the
United States to work in the coal mines
in West Virginia and Pennsylvania but
his mother my grandmother had been
crippled from hard labor and my father
couldn't leave so he stayed in northern
England until he died in 2012 my mother
still lives in my hometown today while
his dream of emigrating to America was
thwarted my father loved America its
culture its history and its role as a
beacon of hope for the world he always
wanted someone in the family to make it
to the United States I began my
university studies in 1984 and I just
learned that I went to the same
university as my colleague here mr.
Holmes and Sint Andrews in Scotland just
thought I would add that and in 1987 I
won a place on an academic exchange to
the Soviet Union I was there for the
signing of the intermediate nuclear
forces our INF treaty and when President
Ronald Reagan met Soviet leader Mikhail
Gorbachev in Moscow this was a turning
point for me an American professor who I
met there told me about graduate
students scholarships the United States
and the very next year thanks to his
advice I arrived in America to start my
Advanced Studies at Harvard years later
I can say with confidence that this
country has offered me opportunities I
never would have had in England I grew
up poor with a very distinctive
working-class accent in England in the
1980s and 1990s this would have impeded
my professional involvement this
background has never set me back in
America for the best part of three
decades I've built a career as a
nonpartisan non-political national
security professional focusing on Europe
and Eurasia and especially the former
Soviet Union I've served our country
under three presidents in my most recent
capacity under President Trump as well
as in my former position under as under
under my former position of national
intelligence officer for Russia and
Eurasia under presidents George W Bush
and Barack Obama in that role I was the
intelligence community's senior expert
on Russia and the former Soviet
republics including Ukraine it was
because of my background and experience
that as I was asked to join the National
Security Council in 2017 at the NSC
Russia was part of my portfolio but I
was also responsible for coordinating
u.s. policy for all of Western Europe
all of Eastern Europe including Ukraine
and Turkey along with NATO and the
European Union
I was hired initially by General Michael
Flynn katie mcfarland and general Keith
Kellogg but then I started work in April
2017 when general McMaster was the
national security adviser I and they
thought that I could help them with
president Trump's stated goal of
improving relations with Russia while
still implementing policies designed to
deter Russian conduct that threatens the
United States including the
unprecedented and successful Russian
operation to interfere in the 2016
presidential election this relates the
second thing I want to communicate based
on questions and statements I've heard
some of you on this committee appear to
believe that Russia and its security
services did not conduct a campaign
against our country and that perhaps
somehow for some reason Ukraine did this
is a fictional narrative that has been
perpetrated and propagated by the
Russian security services themselves the
unfortunate truth is that Russia was the
foreign power that systemically attacked
our democratic institutions in 2016 this
is the public conclusion of our
intelligence agencies confirmed in
bipartisan congressional reports it is
beyond dispute even if some of the
underlying details must remain
classified the impacts of the successful
2016 Russian campaign remains evidence
today our nation is being torn apart
truth is questioned our highly
professional expert career foreign
service is being undermined u.s. support
for Ukraine which continues to face
armed aggression aggression has been
politicized the Russian government's
goal is to weaken our country to
diminish America's global role and to
neutralize a perceived u.s. threat to
Russian interests President Putin and
the Russian security services aim to
counter u.s. foreign policy objectives
in Europe including in Ukraine where
Moscow wishes to reassert political and
economic dominance I say this not as an
alarmist but as a realist I do not think
long term conflict with Russia's are the
desirable or inevitable
I continue to believe that we need to
seek wares of stabilizing our
relationship with Moscow even as we
counter their efforts to harm us right
now Russia's security services and their
proxies have geared up to repeat their
interference in the 2020 election we are
running out of time to stop them and the
cost of this investigation I would ask
that you please not promote politically
driven falsehoods that so clearly
advance Russian interests as Republicans
and Democrats have agreed for decades
Ukraine is a valued partner of the
United States and it plays an important
role in our national security and as I
told the committee last month I refused
to be part of an effort to legitimize an
alternate narrative that the Ukrainian
government is a u.s. adversary and the
Ukraine not Russia attacked us in 2016
these frictions are harmful even if they
are deployed for purely domestic
political purposes President Putin and
Russian security services operate like a
super PAC they deploy millions of
dollars to weaponize our own political
opposition research and false narratives
when we are consumed by partisan rancor
we cannot come by combats these external
forces are there as there seek to divide
us against each other
degrade our institutions and destroy the
faith of the American people in our
democracy I respect the work that this
Congress does and carrying out its
constitutional responsibilities
including this requiring and I'm here to
help you to the best of my ability if
the President or anyone else impedes or
subverts the national security the
United States in order to further
domestic political or personal interests
that's more than worthy of your
attention but we must not let domestic
politics stop us from defending
ourselves against the foreign powers who
truly wishes harm I'm ready to answer
your questions thank you thank you dr.
hill